l a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in
un nuovo blog anche se mercoledì ragazzi
sono veramente giovedì ragazzi comunque
giovedì è anche se giovedì non l'ho
fatto in anticipo al blog
ma adesso vi spiego il perché prima di
tutto vorrei iniziare come al solito con
la parte della settimana anche se non è
finita la settimana e l'afa l'arte della
settimana è stata vinta da francesca che
ha fatto questo figlio disegno dove c'è
scritto grazie ai 600mila iscritti che
poi non ho ancora capito chi è quella
sinistra che comunque non importa la
parata è bellissima grazie mille direi
passare alle news ragazzi perché devo
dire bene di abbastanza importanti alla
graziotto ho fatto blog di mercoledì
perché vorrei mettere quasi 7 di aprile
quindi tra cinque giorni mi parlò non so
più contano tra quattro giorni ragazzi
sarebbe il mio compleanno prime tesi
come e lunedì jolo festeggiò il weekend
quindi di domenica e sabato
e siccome non festeggio non posso fare
non posso fare ovviamente video perché
festeggio i parenti tutti
dolci patatine basuna vabbè comunque
comunque ragazzi la news più importanti
in realtà non sarebbe questa perché
volendo il blog lo potrei anche
registrare ma in teoria da dal 3 di
aprile quindi da quello che state
vedendo questo video
al 12 di aprire quindi nove giorni io
sarò in gita scolastica andrò a barre
vado a barcellona con la mia classe
quindi non sono a casa quindi ragazzi
dal 3 al 12 in teoria non dovrebbero
uscire video perché sono sono a
barcellona però però c'è anche un però
ho registrato ragazzi dei video che ho
messo da parte quindi per essere
caricati nei mentre che sono via e
quindi ragazzi non ci sarà video al
giorno dal 4 al 12 di aprile ma ragazzi
usciranno vi do uno ogni due o tre
giorni fino al 12 e poi ovviamente
ragazzi si riparte normalmente anche
nelle vacanze di pasqua
cerco di dare il massimo e quindi
ragazzi questo è tutto lag la cosa che
volevo anche dire è che molti di voi
sono contenti per il fatto lo so ma
sette sono voi contenti che sta per
uscire outlast il dlc che uscirà doveva
uscire nei primi di aprile dovrebbe
comunque uscirà tra pochissimo quindi
non vedo l'ora che esca e quindi sono
cazzi miei quotato sono contentissimo
che mi sia piaciuto ago simulator che
ormai
veramente non vedevo l'ora che uscisse
anch'io finalmente uscito
siccome ho intenzione di portarlo avanti
tantissimo stasera perché sono un casino
di cose da fare
non avete ancora visto niente digiuno e
dentro queste ragazzine che possiamo
passare l'ho scartato dei pacchi perché
l'ultima volta che ho detto le news sono
detti e per 12 ore e v7 scartavetrato i
[ __ ] giustamente quindi devi passati
stavolta dire di ridurre e passare
subito ai fatti così ci divertiamo di
più ma prima di passare allo scarso dei
pacchi ragazzi volevo dirvi una cosa che
non tutti non tutti sanno perché è
successa è successo domenica al raduno
alle dune che ho fatto a torino ragazzi
è un'idea geniale che mi è venuta visto
il momento e mi sono fatto anche un
video nel mentre che la spiegavo quindi
niente vi lascio al video
giudicate voi
mi hanno visto entrare in questo settore
i primi tre mesi me l era proprio come
uscire sul palco però voglio provare a
fare un'altra ondata advanced esca dai
concentrale lui
al posto mio
e la mia voglio vedere la reazione non
lo scopro che non sono io sarà il mondo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ragazzi è stata la cosa più bella car
una cazzo di volta ragazzi lasciatevi
prendere st soddisfazione perché la
prima volta che vi vedo soffrire io e
non vuoi che mi vedete giocare un horror
sarà uno scherzo dei pochi così almeno
ci divertiamo di più
siccome ragazzi c'è una curiosità che mi
distrugge lo stomaco da quando mi sono
arrivati sui bachi credo di fare in
fretta perché c'è tipo questi ce l'ho da
secoli da un pezzo che doveva aprirli mi
piace questa è questa questa ha vinto a
b
la mia gamba sfg questa era fantastica
grazie mille per tutte le risate che ci
prepara ad ogni profilo speriamo che tu
non smetta mai di stupirci i ti vogliamo
bene parigi nizza
io e la mia gamba sexy vi ringraziamo
non pre capito che cazzo e questo a ma
c'e scritto a vada che variava da chi è
davvero e contro il cat mario se se
cazzo se ho la mia ba è un pezzo al
ramoscello ma chiara ma che cazzo alla
mascella ragazzi è la bacchetta più
potente del mondo vi ringrazio di cuore
per questo potere immenso che userò
soltanto in caso di necessità estrema di
passare al prossimo che è che un po più
gravi ovviamente dietro sempre in ordine
di grandezza che c'è una c'è una mono è
bellissima mi sono innamorato e tratto
ragazzi c'è anche un no vabbè ma questo
caso c'è un minion di cattivissimo me
che c'è anche un tasto dietro grazie
ragazzi è la cosa più bella che io abbia
mai visto
dopo questo sono un ragazzo completo non
mi serve più niente dalla vita addosso
tutto questo questo è veramente
fantateatro ragazzino giusto ai capelli
perfetto perché tu lo prendi
e metti a porcia e fa tutto lui e
meraviglia cucina anche a guardarli che
tantissimo e poi ragazzi mi a picco per
che cazzo mi avete regalato ma è normale
due telefoni ma che è perché mi sono
arrivati due cellulari non so se norma
ma sono finti perché avete capito il mio
essere da solo quanto sono forever alone
e quindi mi chiamò da solo che grazie
mille vite ma adesso si che ciò c'è un
passatempo utile ma voi ragazze dopo
questo direi che possiamo passare al fa
vi risponde la prima domanda ragazzi
arriva da lg cube che mischierà farvi
risponde il quad è che prendi la patente
in realtà l'ho fatto ragazzi perché
cinque o sei lezioni di corso le aveva
seguite soltanto che non ho continuato
ragazzi perché non avevo tempo la scuola
il canale ragazzi e cioè devo
sacrificare qualsiasi cosa per riuscire
a portare avanti tutte e due fare la
patente e una cosa che non potevo
assolutamente fare in questo periodo non
potevo perché non ce la faccio contempo
non ce la faccio quindi aspetto che
finisce la scuola e poi dopo se riesco a
prendere la patente quindi l'ho presa
con l'anno in ritardo perché lo so non
riusciva poi per niente se dovrò seguire
anche le lezioni di guida non ce la
facevo da fare un cazzo già non ce la
faccio adesso ringraziando iddio perché
la mia scuola guida diciamo quello che
so da come si guida hanno imparato su
gta quindi ragazzi non vedo l'ora di
prendere la patente che cazzo state
attenti a uscire di casa mitri anche i
pali risponde quali serie tv se vedi più
io the walking dead non ho proprio idea
di che cosa sia the walking dead poco
mai ma neanche sentito carso per la
prima volta credo fossero già se non mi
dice niente quali risponde a me dovuto
tagliare un pezzo di video perché hai
scoraggiato
[Musica]
favi risponde famiglia grazie venuta
l'ispirazione di fare video di
pubblicarli su youtube comunque sappi
che sei rimarrai non sempre un mitra
grazie mille innanzi tutto ovviamente
solo un insieme di circostanze
complicata che sono intrise tra di loro
è concatenazioni di idee che non ci
avevo un cazzo da fare
famigli sponde quale regalo più grande
che hai ricevuto andrea rinaldi perché
non fai un affari domanda questa è una
genialata se non aver non ci avrei mai
pensato a una cosa del genere quindi
grandissimo direi che possiamo fare
mi piace un casino sta che da adesso in
avanti affido e del fa vi rispondo
ragazzi farò anche una favi domanda voi
rispondete nei commenti se volete con la
risposta comunque ragazzi favi domanda
cazzo di posso chiedere ai ragazzi
qual è il video che vi ha fatto più
ridere in assoluto che ho fatto fino
adesso
scrivete quello che volete non lo so vi
piaccio casinò sta cosa e niente ragazzi
che posso concludere qui per stavolta
pericolosa ragazzi che sono in gita
scolastica in questo periodo quindi dal
dal 4 al 12 di aprile sono a barcellona
quindi non non posso registrare ma
metterò il video che sono riuscito a
registrare nel frattempo e niente
ragazzi direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio come al solito ragazzi se vi
do è piaciuto stato il commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
divido tata nella descrizione se non
siete felici di iscrivetevi noi ci
mettiamo un prossimo vinto bella ragazzi